hello everyone this next game was played
in the 2016 US Championship and although
Fabiano Caruana
want that event one full point ahead of
Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so in my
opinion worthless so played the most
beautiful game of the tournament and
also won the 2017 u.s. championship and
this game wesa so is white and he's
playing against the bar was an okapi on
another very strong american grandmaster
originally from armenia so let's see
this game we have efore by Wesley and d6
by aqua be on b4 b5 the French defense
we have it Knight c3 big captures on e4
Knight captures on e4 Knight to d7 92 s3
nice G to f6 nice casters on f6 Knight
captures on f6 and now C 3 we have c5 by
Aquaman he wants to he wants to exchange
one of the Wesley central pawns so we
have Bishop to e3 and now he plays C
caps or sandy for n bit of characters on
d4 and he did manage to grab Wesley
central born but this Bishop is now an
extremely strong piece so far no no
occupants pieces can oppose it so we
have Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to d3
another very very good bishop and now
both bishops are eyeing that King side
very nicely we have a castle Byakugan
and Queen to c2 kind of harassing that
h7 pawn so aqua beyond plays h6 we have
queenside castle by Wesley so and Queen
to a5 attacking that a to pawn so what's
the play scheme to be won and here we
have a rook to d8
Wesley plays Knight to e5 and we have
Bishop to d7 and in this position of
course Wesley Wesley does not want to
capture this Bishop on d7 even though
that would give him a bishop pair but
this Knight is a monster and this Bishop
well it's not really doing anything if
Wesley will want to see you
he always changes when it comes to c6 if
he decides to do so we have a queen to
e2 and now Bishop to c6 and here was
again doesn't capture the bishop but he
plays rook H to d1
he invites a cobia to capture this pawn
and
- and given an open G line buttock OPM
plays Bishop to d5 now attacking this a2
square and here wasn't pushes c4 and
again he there's our Kobe on to capture
the pawn on g2 and in this position aqua
beyond does capture if he plays Bishop
captures in g2 and well Wesley does want
to put his rook to g1 and occupy that
strong G file but first he has to get to
his own Bishop out of harm's away so he
plays Bishop to c3 with the tempo on the
Queen we have Queen to b6 and now he
plays rook the g1 and like I said this
this was played in 2016 US Championship
between two very very strong
grandmasters and when you're playing
black in this position
you do realize White has an open file
for his work but you're not you're not
thinking that something could really go
wrong here I mean it it's 2016 there are
no any more blistering attacks with
sacrifices and things like that and he
doesn't really feel the danger here if
he if he felt the danger here he would
probably retreat with the bishop to
maybe h3 you know just so we could
defend ecigs and help up with the
protection of the king but after being
played Bishop to c6 here and here Wesley
finds a very romantic idea and he plays
nice captures on f7 and this is this is
the critical position of the game
and nice captures on f7 does have its
objective value as as a move it also has
a psychological value and if octagon had
you know had his composure here he could
probably find a better defense than
capturing the night for example he could
play rooks casters on d3 and well this
was allowed not not nice captures an 86
with Chuck
King to f8 and now rook captures and e3
and simply pinning this work with a
bishop and although a white is better in
this position this is the world it is
playable for black it's not lost but
like I said 97 does have its
psychological value as a move and
ah Cuban decided to capture tonight he
plays team casters on f7 but this allows
Wesley another very romantic idea he
plays rook Catherine g7 with check and I
think aqua been realized now what was
going on he does have to capture the
rook if he tries to refuse the offering
over look-alike with something like King
to f8 he would get the Queen casters and
e6 and now Wesley would be threatening
checkmate on e7 and then f7 and black
cannot stop both threats
so after rook captures and g7 ACOG and
played Oh King captures and g7 and now
the whole point of the of the two
sacrifices a way to place a winged
casters on e6 and now you can see how
these two bishops are extremely strong
there is nothing to protect blacks King
wasn't is threatening Queen captures on
e7 woods check and also an even greater
threat is rook to g1 check so he
Rockabye on gets an idea that well maybe
I should give give something back just
you know to keep me alive and he plays
Queen captures an f2 not allowing the
rook to go to g1 but this is already a
finished game and Wesley finishes is
quite nice he plays Queen captures and
e7 woods check we have King to g8 and
now Wesley plays Bishop to h7 check and
it's over in this position values an
octagon resigned because luck is without
a move you can't really capture the
bishop with the knife because then Queen
to g7 would be checkmate and the Queen
the King has nowhere to go so if you
would play something like King day
chases and simply Bishop captures on f6
and it's all over black has the part
with its Queen and this is with check so
Arthur King captures on h7 you would get
the Queen to d7 g7 check and while both
Brooks will fall and this is well
octagon doesn't doesn't want to allow
this so after Bishop takes 7 check aqua
been resigned so yeah a beautiful game
and a very nicely placed tournament by
voices so you know like I said it's like
morphe played this game another modern
player and like I said he didn't win
first place he won the
with championship 2017 but in my opinion
this is this is the best game of the
tournament well in my opinion so yeah
that's it I hope you enjoyed this game I
surely did and you can check to my
previous videos here if you miss them
and yeah that's it thank you for
watching and I will see you soon